what's up everybody Zaki here with
another fantastic unboxing video 2023 is
gonna be an awesome year for gaming as
you can see we've got the Diablo 4
collector's edition Candlestick right
here how cool is that we've got the live
here and then narius oh and you guys
have not seen that collector's unboxing
video you guys can check it out right
here so many anticipated games dropping
and what we have here is the Final
Fantasy Collector's Edition for the
PlayStation 5. I mean just take a look
at this box art guys
take a look at all the icons we've got
the Phoenix here
and all the other cool stuff wow just
look at the model detail it's foil it's
reflective hi guys you can see me over
there nice
and at the back it's just a very simple
Final Fantasy 16 logo right there how
cool is that just want to give a shout
out to PlayStation Asia for letting us
unbox this so let's get on with it now
the collector's edition is pretty hard
to come by I believe it's pretty much
sold out in most places and the Final
Fantasy 16 collector's edition is priced
about 500 Singapore dollars or about 350
US Dollars now as you can tell it's
probably got a ton of goodies so let's
check it out so what we have on the top
box is Clive Rosefield
very nice let's see what's inside let's
see what we got right here wow okay
and what we have here is the cloth map
of Valencia
very interesting nice texture too so as
you can probably tell by the map itself
the map is going to be very very huge of
course we can't forget the steelbook
case
there we go very classy
iconic Final Fantasy steelbook case with
a Clive Rosefield once again and you can
see by the highlights of the light here
let me see what I can grab it real quick
see how it's embossed
like kind of popping out the steel case
which is pretty cool and this is what
the spine looks like
and the inside of the steelbook case
and I forgot to mention with the
collectors edition it will include all
the pre-order bonuses including the
scholar spectacles Braveheart sword the
Kate Sith charm accessory and a unique
digital item the blood sword and we
can't forget about these lovely metal
icon pins so what we have here is eight
metal icon pins icons with an extra e
and let's break down each of these pins
the first icon is the Phoenix pretty
nice well done you also have some
colored backing here so this is in a
nice deep purplish red going on or
magenta red
very nice the second one is the lovely
Sheba
and the third one we have the bearded
rubber
very cool man
the fourth one here is Bahamut
number five is Garuda nice green back in
here what we have here is Titan with a
yellow backing
and number seven is Odin with the
antlers that's pretty cool
and the last one here is
Ifrit
so that covers the metal icons of Final
Fantasy 16. you can pretty much wear
this every single day of the week and
one more for the special days like your
birthday or your spouse's anniversary to
tell your story
yeah
and of course we are gonna move on to
the peace style of resistance the Final
Fantasy 16 premium statue of Phoenix
versus Ifrit but before we get into it
geek culture is supported by friends
like yourself who help us improve our
videos so let's hear from today's
sponsor here geek culture we've tested
plenty of chairs but Secret Life gaming
chairs remain one of our favorites
whether it's for work or play they feel
great to lean back against with the
ergonomic features offering support for
the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of format
function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co come to me if Rich yes we
are finally back to unbox this statue so
let's check it out man I'm so excited to
see this
so let's get it out come on there we go
get this out of the way you guys ready
and cut
there we go only one piece and there's
no assembly required folks all one piece
for what's worth it's pretty light and
the feathers on Phoenix is pretty bendy
so you just gotta be mindful not to like
grab like the tail ends or even the
feathers pretty much snap something so
you got to be really really careful of
the statue but man look at the colors on
this
look how Phoenix's um wings are man
she
guys just look at the amount of detail
on if it's face there blocking off
Phoenix oh man just look at the muscles
on E3 it's claws
look at the clothes
man
guys I'm totally speechless I am loving
the colors
and the amount of detail in this
check out the armor on his legs his foot
I would say the Rocks cut off a little
bit better work on that but
I mean let's start the shows right here
man
I'm gonna call this a solid 9 out of 10
folks the only reason why it's losing
one point is because the uh the thing's
not a solid seeds it's kind of wobbling
but the help of some standoffs or some
tape I think we should be leveling it
just fine it's gonna be perfect for our
geek display on the back
so I can't wait to show it off to my
friends
and this is the
SE different map of the last year we
have the Clive Rosefield steelbook case
eight metal icon pins the lovely statue
of Phoenix versus e Fred not to mention
the physical copy of the game and its
bonus DLCs if you like this video you
guys know what to do leave us a thumbs
up and let us know down in the comments
whether you guys are gonna get
yourselves one of these don't forget to
follow us on all our socials And
subscribe to the channel it goes a long
way with that said we'll see you on the
next unboxing bye bye now
thank you
[Music]